with a divine twist and one hell of an
ending the final season of lucifer
delivers an incredibly emotional
send-off for all our favorite characters
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're taking a deep dive into the
finale to uncover and explain all the
clues and details you might have missed
plus we'll discuss whether a season 7 or
spin-off could still be possible
spoilers ahead of course so take care
although lucy fought a battle to be the
new god in season 6 he finds himself
full of doubts about whether he's really
the right angel for the job and by the
end he realizes his true calling isn't
to rule on high but to help redeem the
souls of the damned below when he said
hell no longer needs to keep her it
doesn't it needs a healer after all who
better to help those condemned to hell
than lucifer who'd lived there for
millennia in his own hell loop of sorts
believing it was his job to punish
people it wasn't until he went to la and
began therapy with dr linda that he was
able to slowly deal with his anger and
self-loathing it took him years to fully
understand himself and during that time
he almost transformed entirely into a
monstrous devil form at the end of
season four his devil face which was
seen since the show began was a crucial
part of lucy's sense of guilt and
self-hatred as god explained to his son
why did you choose that face deep down
that face is how you see yourself so
when lucifer sees his daughter rory
giving in to her anger and manifesting
her own devil face against lemek he
recognizes it for what it is and begs
her not to give in to those urges
killing him won't change what he's done
but it will change you i know what it's
like to be consumed by guilt
by anger and self-hatred as rory later
explains lucifer has a special gift that
troubled people like her can relate to
when i looked in your eyes i knew you
understood my anger and the guilt more
than anyone else could and when lucy
chloe and rory realized that it was his
advice to dan's ghosts that helped him
finally ascend to heaven chloe explains
that helping those who are stuck within
their own guilt-ridden hell loops could
be lucifer's true purpose you can help
everyone every dan down in hell who
deserves another chance lucy agrees and
thinks he'll be able to do the job
part-time which does make some sense
when you consider that time in hell
moves differently so he could be down
there delivering hundreds or thousands
of years of therapy and only be gone in
earth time for a few months however rory
explains that wouldn't be possible
because if lucifer is there for her as a
father as she grows up she'll never
become angry enough to time travel to
the past and help him arrive at this
moment of self-discovery that he could
help rescue millions of condemned souls
in hell we can't change anything or he
might never get that idea what rory is
describing is a type of time paradox
which you can pick apart if you start to
think about it too much so i suggest for
pure enjoyment of the show just to go
along with it my advice don't overthink
it in fact this season six storyline
with lucy and chloe's daughter rory
being crucial to his ultimate destiny
fits nicely as one of the reasons he was
so insistent on bringing chloe back from
heaven at the end of season five it's
not your time your knees to come back
there were also some theories at the end
of season five that chloe getting
stabbed in the stomach with a staff made
from the tree of life would lead to her
pregnancy and given that i like how rory
is framed in this shot with a tree of
knowledge and the stained glass window
to her side lucy and chloe's final
moments together on earth as they ready
themselves for him to go to hell will no
doubt have been heartbreaking for deca
star fans and even more so because this
scene mirrors the first time they met in
the pilot lucifer morningstar is that uh
a stage name or something
god-given i'm afraid lucifer morningstar
is that like a stage name or something
god-given i'm afraid and when they play
heart and soul together it's a tender
callback to the first time they dueted
with that song in season one i think
you're gonna miss my incredible musical
prowess the moment
and lucy also played heart and soul in
the third season episode quintessential
deca star as a way to remind chloe of
their time together before pierce came
along and the albanian field wench
mention is also a cute shout out to the
first season when chloe woke up in
lucy's bed after getting drunk the night
before you snore by the way like an
albanian field wench fortunately though
the sweet part of the bittersweet ending
promised by the showrunners is still to
come when decades later after chloe dies
she goes to the afterlife and a menadil
takes her to hell to reunite with
lucifer proving they really are partners
to the end hello detective i thought you
could use a partner lucy fans will
surely love that they got to hear
lucifer call chloe detective one final
time which neatly parallels the start of
the season when lucy called her by her
name and she replied still not used to
you calling me that that very last time
he calls her detective is also a nice
way of acknowledging that although chloe
gave up her police job at the end of
season five so she could help lucy in
his godly duties being a detective was
still very much part of her dna and we
saw that in the first episode of season
six when chloe just couldn't stop
herself investigating the magician
murder scene once the detective always
the detective and remember this deca
star reunion in hell will be especially
sweet for lucifer given that while
decades have passed on earth between
lucy leaving and chloe's death it's
probably been hundreds of thousands if
not a few million years in hell time for
lucifer i love the fact that lucifer's
therapy room in hell appears to be a
replica of dr linda's office proving
just how great her influence on him has
been and it's interesting that after
lucy counseled the good doctor in season
five on how she could reconcile with her
daughter she told him this awfully
insightful of you lucifer maybe you
should become a therapist on lucifer's
couch in hell is rhys linda's ex-husband
whose hell loop made up the season 3
episode off the record even now reece
still can't break out of his loop but
lucifer is there diligently advising him
to confront his guilt head on rather
than avoiding it and when re says he
feels like a lost cause lucifer's reply
sums up the show's key premise because
if the devil can be redeemed then anyone
can now let's get into that final
montage revealing how everyone else
ended up at the close of the series it
begins in the silver city with a mena
deal taking his place as a menace god
which many lucy fans suspected would
happen given his desire to help people
and how well-suited he seems for the
position after all remember the advice
about humanity he gave lucy back in
season four humans chloe people are
amazing i'm only now just realizing how
lucky that we are that we actually get a
chance to connect with them and then
there were his wonderful words to ella
in season five about her feelings that
she didn't fully deserve god's love you
see i think if god was standing right
here right now in front of you that he
would tell you to take some of that
faith that you have in him and put it in
yourself and as it turns out amenities
words foreshadowed his rise to god's
status similar to his brother menadil
also wants to reform his part of the
cosmos and make heaven a better place i
think every single angel should spend
time here walking among humans just like
i did to get to really
understand humanity he also agreed with
lucifer to take joint ownership of looks
and in the montage we see him gather his
team of angels who will send to work at
lucy's club so they can mix with all
types of humans and rather than
operating in the mysterious ways of
their father who left his family to work
out things by themselves and then a god
plans to involve his angelic siblings in
god's work and keep them informed being
god is what i truly desire with the men
a deal now firmly in charge of heaven
the closing montage shows ella caressing
her cross her faith renewed as she
senses a big guy has returned in some
ways ella underwent perhaps the most
dramatic arc of all in the final season
as she finally discovered the truth
about her celestial friends something
teased all the way back in the god
johnson episode of season two is it
really so crazy i mean what if god was
one of us many lucy fans were hoping
ella would find out the truth especially
as in season five she actually met god
himself who helped her through the
darkness she was feeling at the time the
darker the darkness the brighter the
light and you miss lopez
shine so very very brightly i can see it
all the way from heaven ella must have
had a few suspicions before then but god
talking about seeing her from heaven and
then disappearing mysteriously seems to
have been the trigger for her secret
investigation and conspiracy board in
season six and by the time of mays and
eve's wedding ella's suspicions are all
but confirmed as she sees a menadil
talking to an invisible dan and carol
comments about the strange smell at the
ceremony what'd you think we were at
some like hell monster wedding attended
by decaying zombies
at the after party ella can't take it
anymore and blurts out she knows the
truth i know that lucifer is the actual
devil not like the most method actor
ever that's a reference to what she said
to lucifer when they first met in season
two and he told her his name are you the
devil a method actor
when chloe confirms the truth to ella
she's not shocked because she already
believed in celestial beings but she is
angry with everyone for excluding her
from the club but by the time lucifer
says farewell in the next episode ella's
now at peace thanks to her chat with
carol and understands why they never
told her you don't have to
know everything to have trust not when
you know each other's hearts and given
how many happy geeky t-shirts we've seen
ella worth throughout the series i can't
think of a better way to signal that the
young woman's stem foundation that lucy
established for her is up and running
than by showing her hand out those
t-shirts the montage neck shows chloe
returning to the lapd part of the plan
that she discussed with the mena deal to
be god's point person in the police
department notice there's a time skip
neck so that when we come back to chloe
we can see she's been promoted and that
she's taken the opportunity to promote
officer harris to detective hopefully
given the show's theme of growth chloe's
using the powers at her disposal now to
change the system along with colleagues
like harris a mena deal even pops by to
check in on things something that harris
seems to sense as after all they had
worked together the montage also checks
in on dan who as so many of us expected
made it to heaven to be with his true
love charlotte richards and of course he
gets to eat pudding plus which as we
know from season three is what dan
prefers putting plus is my favorite okay
twice as much protein as all the other
brands some more fun details in this
scene of the 40 whole years of being
damn mug referencing the time he was
alive on earth and the fact that
charlotte's getting waffles for her
heavenly treat is a call back to the
waffle maker that dan bought her in
season three shortly before she was
killed in season six we learned that the
lingering guilt holding dan back from
heaven was his belief that he wasn't a
good enough role model to his daughter
trixie when he goes to visit her in
lamech's body he confesses these
feelings however trixie replies that he
was the best dad ever but he made so
many mistakes everyone makes mistakes
and my dad taught me that mistakes are
important we need them so that we could
learn and do better next time this is
again the big theme of the whole series
that there is always a path for anyone
to redemption and as trixie tells dan
that she's proud of her dad the guilt he
feels washes away and a light calls him
up to heaven
as the montage continues we get to see
charlie celebrating his second birthday
and as predicted a set of wings pop out
proving he has celestial traits after
all amena deal gives a little punch in
the air as he's clearly delighted as
many lucy fans will also be charlie
being an angel also resolves the plot
point from season 4 about why ramiel
sensed the birth of a new celestial on
earth as to why charlie's wings didn't
show up until now it's likely because as
a newborn he was too young to
self-actualize if that's the case it
seems like linda's attempt to raise the
best child possible by giving baby
charlie access to an incredible range of
classes from japanese to art
appreciation has paid off helping him to
develop and self-actualise at a very
young age the montage also catches us up
with everyone's favorite demon maze who
turned down the opportunity to rule hell
together with eve a theory i mentioned
back in season four instead thanks to
linda's dinner table therapy maze
explains that rather than torturing
souls in hell what she really wants to
do is carry on as a bounty hunter on
earth so much better when they're still
alive you know you can really feel the
fear during that dinner table session
mays tells eve that she's her true hell
and so by the end we see they've found
their bliss hunting down and punishing
perps something eve also enjoys as we
saw how she relished doing that with
lucifer in season four maize's farewell
with lucy was exceptionally emotional
and when she gives him her demon blade
it's especially significant because her
knives have been an integral part of her
since we met her in season one no matter
what you will always
have a piece of me in fact that demon
blade is likely her last one as the
other one was melted down at the end of
season 5 to create the demon blade
bullets that chloe used in the celestial
battle at the olympic stadium the
montage concludes with a phone call and
news that baby rory has been born and
maze's excitement at the knife gift
she's brought for the newly born babe
reminds me of the scene when she was
showing trixie an assortment of weapons
in season four and slipped her blade on
the way out may as you know she's not
allowed to play with mice relax dan
these knives aren't for trixie for a
baby i thought the way the series
wrapped up was really well done and
although it's been confirmed this really
is the final season it's nice to imagine
that lucifer and chloe's story could
continue in some form down in hell they
already both worked a case down there in
season six when they investigated jimmy
bonds as hell loop it's unlikely we'll
be getting a season seven anytime soon
but other popular shows have been
resurrected years later and with the
number of resurrections this series has
already had anything's possible would
you like to see a season 7 or a spin-off
show and if so what would you like to
see in it so what did you think of the
final season of lucifer comment with
your thoughts and theories below and if
you enjoyed this video a like and a
share are hugely appreciated tap left to
watch my next loose of a video or tap
right for something else you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time yippie kay movie lovers
you